comment ça va aller bien tout se passe
bien bon il ya quelques semaines je vous
avais demandé de m'envoyer des vidéos
avec vos plus belles et astuces pour
smartphones que ce soit sur un os sur
android et donc les regarder et voir si
des choses que je vais découvrir que je
ne connais pas tous loin de là on va
commencer par celle d'arthur et c'est
justement là moi je vous présenter mon
astuce donc que si par exemple vous avez
un samsung galaxy donc ça peut être une
tablette ou un téléphone galaxy déjà
hockey et que vous avez pas youtube
premium donc le bal a par exemple c'est
mon cas et pas l'abbé bas que vous
voulez avoir youtube en fond de tâche
donc la vidéo qui se lisent comme ça au
calme donc ce que vous faites c'est que
vous avez dans le multitâche
ouais vous cliquez sur le lincoln de
l'application vous faites open une pop
view open in one il l ue voilà nickel et
bien là c'est pas vraiment ce qu'on veut
l'on veut vraiment juste la vidéo donc
ce que vous allez faire c'est que vous
aidez up recadrer la vidéo donc voila
comme cela ça se met en grand écran pour
moi ça ça se met ça se met tous bien
ouais et documents là vous pouvez aller
sur vous pouvez faire n'importe quoi
donc là vous pouvez aller sur reddit et
puis bah lire votre vidéo voilà comme ça
il va vous pouvez faire ce que vous
voulez
et puis va avoir tout le temps votre
vidéo qui ici puis si vous voulez homme
voulant remettre en prend et donc voilà
je trouve ça super bien voilà hockey
ouais bien bien arthur bien oui
effectivement là l'idée c'est de pouvoir
mettre ta fenêtre comme tu veux donc
soit faire du multitâche faire partager
écran aux écrans bac un peu plus
classique soit se dire je profitais
d'une seule et grande fenêtre et en même
temps une petite fenêtre que je peux
venir déplacer ok pas mal open in pop
view à obtenir on va maintenant aller
celle de ice aide
salut à tous à lui monsieur greuet merci
cédric de la chaîne y cède ma petite
astuce veut être connus mais utile a
rappelé pour les possesseurs de
smartphones ou tablettes android surtout
ceux qui ont des modèles plutôt anciens
celle ci va vous permettre de réduire le
temps des animations logiciel de votre
appareil pour ainsi donner une
impression d'accélération lors de
l'utilisation pour ce faire vous devez
déjà activé les options pour les
développeurs dans les paramètres de
votre smartphone ou tablette pour cela
attends attends ta ta ta ta ta ta part
déjà il ya un truc qui est pas mal la
mère a tenté une cane
j'efface pas ta vidéo ce qui est pas mal
là déjà ce que tu fais c'est
l'incrustation de ta capture d'écran
dans un téléphone avec la perspective
j'avais l'impression que c'était l'hymne
on voit en fait que c'est pas réellement
sain mais bien vachement bien fait ça
c'est super membres pour les
développeurs dans les paramètres de
votre smartphone ou tablette pour cela
rendez vous dans à propos du téléphone
ensuite dans numéro de build puis
appuyer plusieurs fois jusqu'à activer
ces nouvelles options presque dans ce
nouvel angle est allé à échelle
d'animation vous avez trois réglages
possibles passé les 3 / 0 5
vous pouvez aussi les mettre à zéro si
pour vous le changement n'est pas
flagrant je rappelle que cela ne joue
pas sur les performances de votre
appareil
seulement sur la vitesse des animations
lors de la navigation et que cette
astuce conviendra plutôt aux anciens
appareils sans écrans 120 hertz ni
processeur ultraperformant comment
trouve maintenant elle promet de donner
un coup de boost à votre smartphone ou
tablette android a testé à la prochaine
bye bye
merci oui il connaissait ça
effectivement ça je l'avais déjà vu
c'est bien parce que les certains
smartphones qui vont venir à mes abdos
moment au niveau des animations ça c'est
pas mal je connaissais d'ailleurs si
vous connaissiez vous en bas en
commentaire maintenant celle de jordan
jordan bonjour à tous je suis jordan je
suis utilisateur au pot je vais vous
dévoiler ma fonctionnalités préférées de
montreynaud callière déjà oppose pas si
vous connaissez je vais faire une vidéo
lac des astuces des smartphones de peau
hâlée coloro s il ya plein de petites
fonctions était super cool sur kolo est
ce donc ça c'est vachement intéressant
connaître alors qu'est ce que tu nous
montres jordan alors c'est très simple
c'est le mode multitâche toujours apparu
comme complexe en fait il est super
simple sur ses téléphones
je suis par exemple ici sur le mode
youtube ou prenez trois doigts up du bas
vers le haut tout simplement et ensuite
vous n'avez plus qu'à sélectionner
l'application que vous voulez divisés
ensuite je peux même vous et affiné
avisé opère intuitif ans c'est ça que
j'aime beaucoup à celle opposant le
coloré saison fait un boulot de dingue
sur l'expérience c'est vraiment super
super intuitif
je vous propose de rentrer directement
dans l'écran pour vous voyez ce que ça
donne
nous voici dans le vif du sujet donc je
suis bien sûr je suis à voir
j'adore j'adore me fait tellement bien
en train de regarder ma petite femme au
hockey et pour diviser mon
écran en deux hommes les trois doigts du
bas vers le haut je choisis ensuite mon
application et je peux même je vais
régler l'avenir site de les mettre
je peux même regarder bien hop par un
simple clic changer la position des
applications à j'aime bien hyper
efficace effectivement mais ça on en
reparlera de colorer saint-pascal plein
de trucs à raconter et ça marche
vraiment bien
julien maintenant astuces du jour comme
enregistré une vidéo top 100 le logo tik
tok donc pour commencer il va falloir
aller sur safari et taper des tic toc
des tuiles qu'on clique sur le site
jean claude gripon comme et on va faire
quitte charcute ensuite on va descendre
tout en bas et ensuite on va cliquer sur
ajouter un raccourci non fiables non
fiables plate lors vous dirigez dans
réglages accessibilité ensuite toucher
on descend tout en bas et on clique sur
toucher le dos de l'appareil
moi j'ai choisi trois fouilles ouais
ensuite on sélectionne le raccourci des
tic toc ça ce système en fait de venir
appuyer plusieurs fois dessus ce
raccourci qui ai connu un qui est très
très très connu par si vous le
connaissez
on peut venir paramétré en touchant
plusieurs fois son dos ça va créer
différentes actions note là notamment
ait choisi l'application des tic ensuite
on choisit une vidéo on appuie sur la
petite flèche copier le lien et on
tapote 3 x 1 2 3 ont fait bloc
ok et voilà la vidéo est enregistrée
sans le logo tik tok
ah ouais ça c'est très drôle mais
attention problèmes de droits d'auteurs
la vidéo non moment là récupéré comme ça
c'est limite limite mais ok je
connaissais pas là sinon mathieu rien
sur eux ça n'arrête les pratiques sur la
narration android plutôt que de voir
accéder directement aux paramètres via
le long pas nous l'a bien galère
ouais faut directement accéder aux
paramètres de wifi bluetooth ou ou
géolocalisation directement en restant
appuyé sur l'icône correspondante
c'est assez pratique et c'est beaucoup
plus rapide voilà je vais faire une
petite doublettes pour ceux qui
expriment la lente et de fer de lance
des applications à la main via le
panneau tout en maintenant sa note par
exemple vous voulez tout ferme et
directe
à nous de trouver garder quelques
applications comme par exemple les
applications de
j'ai fait plusieurs pas plusieurs donc
j'ai connecté à tu peux faire est juste
resté appuyé et verrouiller cette
application ça la protège je connaissais
pas ça ça les empêche de faire mieux
excellent bonne journée à je connaissais
pas ça monsieur
ah ça c'est pas mal ça ok donc en fait
je peux choisir les applications que je
ne pourrais pas fermé sauf si je lai
déverrouille ok ça je connaissais pas du
tout vous connaissiez vous d'ailleurs
dit que le manga en commentaire parce
que ça vraiment pour le coup je
connaissais pas cool merci
remy 7 ckoi ipad voilà on arrive écran
d'accueil et de thèmes déroulement des
icônes ok et ensuite qu'est ce qui se
passe
tac
ok c'est très étrange sans voix je vais
dans le plextor dites moi si vous
comprenez pas ce que j'ai du mal à
comprendre en fait ce qui se passe c'est
être moins 25 secondes de jeu sait pas
on devra essayer de comprendre parce que
je comprends parfaite donc là je suis
sur mon smartphone
ok je mets ou d'être mes réglages je
vais dans les réglages devenant le
déroulement des icônes geste
d'accord vous qu'avec le geste je viens
réduire sur le côté ça en fait j'ai fait
un geste sur le côté ça permet de
réduire pour la voir en usage à une main
en fait ok j'ai compris
ok ça marche moi c'est sympa c'est très
sympa bonjour je vais vous montrer
comment cloné une application
directement depuis entre 800 utilise
d'applications tierces pour cela il faut
respecter une chose il faut avoir un
smartphone qui tourne sur me wade 12 la
surcouche de xian et vous aller dans les
paramètres applications clooney et là
vous avez toutes les applications que
vous pouvez clonés alors à quoi ça sert
si vous êtes un vendeur sur ebay et que
vous achetez peut-être un cadeau de
comptes que vous avez deux comptes et
faire comme si un ancien professionnel
et prix du privé du coup ce que vous
pouvez faire vous cochez la petite case
il colle été ajouté à votre écran avec
lg ib qui a été cloné on la lance on a
directement ebay sans recommandation
look là j'ai mon application voilà vous
connectez vous inscrire alors j'ai
toutes les fonctionnalités idée merci
monsieur greuze de m'avoir fait passer
dans ta vidéo merci la doit surtout
justin ces luttes monsieur vous
expliquer comme justin rendre
téléphone beaucoup plus rapide à ta ta
ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta
ta ta juste c'est quoi ça derrière on
voit une boîte de au nord au nord de
femmes ok alors pour ce faire nous
allons regarder dans les paramètres vous
allez tout en mode vous paramètres dans
à propos du téléphone
ouais et vous appuyez plusieurs fois sur
numéro du build là bas
oui mais vous êtes déjà plein de
développeurs devenir un développeur ont
fait retour et on m'a dans ce système
est mise à jour dans options pour
développeurs ouais la même chose et là
on descend dans la partie du milieu la
partie tracé ici i
on va pouvoir accélérer ou ou d
accélérer son téléphone
l'animation en fait la magie sauf que
tout à l'heure par tous là on voit que
l'animation est plus lente
j'avais jamais ça y opposent une fin
moins longue
oh la vache
ils passent la journée pendant ce temps
là est il du coup un jour ajouter 2 mai
tout en x 10.5 comme ça vous allez
pouvoir gagner deux à trois secondes par
ci par là et on voit que c'est beaucoup
plus rapide comme ça ouais merci merci
merci justin c'est la même astuce sauf
que elle est illustrée comme ça c'est
assez intéressant effectivement fodil
avais-je pas me laisser y est assez
sympa alors plein de petites
fonctionnalités hyper cool en fait c'est
des fonctionnalités logicielles et tout
ça effectivement on s'en reparlera plus
tard parce que je vous en ai déjà parlé
notamment des fonctionnalités de huanuco
de samsung j'ai beaucoup parlent
également de fonctionnalités d'apple on
va parler des fonctionnalités de coloris
dopo et puis on a parlé de mireuil aussi
de xiaomi me why does justement
comparable plein d'odeurs dites moi si
ça peut vous intéresser de kehl
type d'astuces vous auriez besoin et de
quel smartphone vous avez qu à ce
personnage j'ai compris que je parle
plus que français pas bien compris
histoire marquée voit ça on va en
commentaire moi j'ai bien aimé en tout
cas faire cette vidéo découvrir
justement ces différentes astuces pour
une fois c'est pas moi qui vais les crée
ce sont vous face et vous dites moi si
vous voyez comment tant d'autres vidéos
réaction comme ça sur vos astuces ou ça
assez marrant mark et moi ça bien
évidemment en bas en commentaire le nom
se retrouve très vite des bisous l'amour
et à bientôt ciao